[Music]
state of California is struggling
financially everybody knows that for
example the California city of Fresno is
462 million dollars in debt and on the
verge of bankruptcy so I'm a native here
of California now not a native but I
live here and a couple of weeks ago I
offered to help solve
Fresno's financial problems you're
welcome by giving them a tourist magnet
okay
giving them something that draws huge
crowds wherever it is and crowds of
course mean people spending money I'm
talking about the world's largest bobble
head
the one and only conan bobble head
[Applause]
[Applause]
what a gift to give to Fresno yeah okay
it would turn things around for them
well the people of Fresno got so excited
about our offer that they just sent us
this nicely produced video response this
is from Fresno here's a clip there's a
place
[Music]
[Music]
they sent us that it's sweet it's a very
nice video yeah okay here's the problem
if we give Fresno the Conan bobblehead
conservative estimates are that it will
generate thirty seven million dollars in
tourist revenue but in the video Fresno
just made they parried the beach voice
on Kokomo without their permission
so now Fresno owes the Beach Boys 82
million dollars in licensing fees and
while I'm fine with Fresno using my
likeness in their video they put a
life-sized cutout of me on a children's
merry-go-round which makes me look like
a creep and a weirdo that's classic
defamation of character of Fresno you
owe me 25 million dollars for slander
plus another 65 million dollars in
punitive damages all of that means the
city of Fresno is now an additional 135
million dollars in debt
[Applause]
[Music]
until you get your act together
financially I cannot give you the Conan
bobblehead it must stay here I'm sorry
but I don't want to leave you
empty-handed
so in the meantime I'm sending you
Fresno the good people of Fresno the
equally exciting and slightly smaller
Andy Richter bobblehead
I've never seen you do that with your
head ever I don't like what you're doing
to it
smacking him like that oh you'll learn
to like it anyway